[Music]
in 2021 my brother mat you and I with
the help of cor neelsen of Philip ctin
introduce all of you to a New Vision of
Storytelling we launched the God's dog
monster graphic novel through
crowdfunding introducing the dog-headed
St Christoper the dragon slang St George
to full view as a new epic story began
the response was astounding reaching
over
$250,000 and ultimately selling out our
first print of the book now book two of
five in this series God's dog Warrior
moves into the meat of this epic story
where our dog Headed Stranger must be
integrated must be trained and must
fight the cosmic Stakes behind the story
become clear the character shine and
heart-wrenching choices must be made
book two will surprise you with more
monsters
more Giants and a deeper exploration of
the mythology underlying it all since
book one of God's dog I've also started
a publishing company called symbolic
World Press with some amazing Partners
to deal with the timely production
Printing and shipping of all future
books we've already successfully
published Snow White and the Widow Queen
and will expand our activities rapidly
the money we raise is to build this
whole project and even move towards
other media we now have three full-time
people working with us plus nine artists
six writers collaborating towards at
least 14 upcoming books and all of this
without any outside funding no outside
control it's all of you making this
possible this is why crowdfunding is so
powerful it's on this crowdfunding we've
partnered with professional comic artist
Matt Shen Jesse White Philip ctin and
Martin crotz to bring together God's dog
Warrior but on top of that I'm also
introducing an entirely new comic book
series called the garments of skin which
will explore the lore the mythology
around God's dog bring the story Into
the Contemporary world where new Heroes
try to resist a global system of
control we are at a turning point in
culture a turning point in storytelling
and I know I can count on all of you to
make it possible we have to take back
the Reigns of Storytelling move past The
Gatekeepers and I thank all of you for
trusting us to play a part in that thank
you for backing God's dog Warrior on
Kickstarter
[Music]
today